على مكان زرقوان بدل من علامات واحده منصه
تنبر تطرح اعلان جديد منافس وفاخر من
التويتر العلامتين الزرقاء
للمقابل
7.99 دولار لمره واحده فقط بدا اعلان
للمنافسه مع تويتر خصوصا لاعاده باعاده
بقوه الى ساحه الفضاء الالكتروني منذ
استحواذ الهوم ماسك على تويتر والتي
صاحبها مشاكل كثيره وجها ماسك وشريكته
شديده وبدات
تنمر بحمله اعلانيه جديده لتشجيع
المستخدمين على العوده الى المنصه التي
كانت شائعه عام 2007 حين اسس ديفيد كارت
هذه المنصه الذي اشتهر بطبيعته الساخره
والاكثر فوضويه من تويتر الرئيس التنفيذيه
الحالي لهذه المنصه همم كشف ان الموقع
يعمل الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى وان النشاط
عليه فاق التوقعات كما ان تحميل التطبيق
ارتفع الى
858 على اجهزه ابل و 57% على اجهزه
اندرويد خلال نوفمبر الماضي وانا اكثر من
18 مليون مستخدم زار الموقع خلال اكتوبر
شركه ياهو كانت اشتركت عامه واشترت عام
2013 هذه المنصه باكثر من مليار دولار
وبلغ عدد المدونات على المنصه اكثر من 200
و15 مليون مدونه حيث يستطيع المستخدم
انشاء اكثر من مدونه عام 2014
[موسيقى]